ما اهم ما سجلته من ملاحظات وطوفان الاقصى
قد بلغت اليوم
المئه يعني واضح انه هذا هذا التقرير وافي
وشامل شرح كيف اعد الجيش الاسرائيلي نفسه
وكيف تمكن في ال يوم الاوائل من على مدار
500 ساعه من قصف تمهيدي وتدمير وهو اطول
قصف مدفعي وبطي وجوي في العالم حتى في
الحربين العالميه الاولى والثانيه لم يحدث
مثل هذا القصف ان ان قلنا انه تمهيدي
ولكنه حقيقه مستمر حتى اليوم ولكن لم
يتقدم الجيش الاسرائيلي في حرب بريه الا
بعد ان تم تسويه المباني بالارض وبعد
سياسه الارض المحروقه وبعد حرب الاباده
الجماعيه وهذه تسجل لصالح المقاومه وليس
لصالح الجيش الاسرائيلي لانه كان
يختبئ ويتحصن بدبابته
وباليت رغم ان 500 ساعه من القصف التدميري
والتمهيدي لم تكفيه حتى يترجل من دبابته
ومن اليته وحينما جاء عبر المحاور الثلاثه
استطاعت المقاومه الفلسطينيه بتكتيكات
رائعه ان تستخدم نقاط قوتها وليست كامله
بمعنى انها احتفظت بالقوه الرئيسيه
الموجات التاليه وليست الموجات الاولى
وهذه من انا بتقديري من قواعد الحرب
الفدائيه ان تستخدم نقاط قوتك امام نقاط
ضعف العدو ان لا تواجه عدوك وهو وهو في
ذروه قدراته وقواته فبالتالي هم استطاعوا
ان يدرجوا الجيش الاسرائيلي الى مسافات
بالعمق لمسافه كيلو متر 2 م ومن ثم بدات
الكمائن وبدات الاج شباكات من مسافه صفر و
وتفجير الدبابات من خلال الاكواع الفدائي
ومن خلال الاربي جيهات او قواذف
الياسين
ثم استطاعوا ان ينتشروا في كل مكان وصل
اليه الجندي الاسرائيلي ووصلت اليه
الدبابه الاسرائيليه
وهنا كان منع الجندي الاسرائيلي من تحقيق
اهدافه بمعنى ان لا يترجل على الارض
ويسيطر على الارض
وان يحرم من الدفاع عن النفس ان يبقى في
حاله قلق وهذا ما جرى مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
لذلك في البدايات كان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يخوض حرب متحركه بمعنى انه الجندي
الاسرائيلي يبقى بالدبابه وباليه ومسنده
من الطائرات ومن المدفعيه وهذا ما جعله
غير قادر على تحقيق اي من الانجازات لذلك
بعد بعد فتره على ما يقارب شهر ونص تقريبا
ذهب الى الهدنه لانه وخاصه بعد السقوط
الاخلاقي وحصار المستشفيات
وتمثيليه مستشفى الشفاء حينما قال ان
قياده المقاومه هناك وان الاسرى هناك
وتبين انها كذبه كبرى ففشل في تحقيق
اهدافه في الشمال وفي الوسط لذلك
ذهب الى ما جاء له بمثابه انقاذ وهي
الهدنه وتباد وتحرير طيب لواء واصف عوده
عوده الحديث الاسرائيلي مره اخرى بالسيطره
على محور فيلادلفيا بعد 100 يوم وما شهدته
من عمليات كيف تقرا هذا
المؤشر اخي عبد القادر يعني المرحلتين
الاولى والثانيه من من وجهه نظر اسرائيل
كانت هي الهدفين ال الذان اعلنا عنهما وهو
القضاء على المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتحرير
اسرى بالقوه العسكريه فشلوا فلذلك يعني
ذهبوا الى مستشفيات والى مستشفى الشفاء
ايضا فشلوا بعد بعد الهدنه وبعد بعد تبادل
الاسرى قالوا سنذهب الى المرحله الثالثه
وهي خان يونس وتحديدا قيادات المقاومه
وسموا بالاسم السنوار فشلوا ايضا وحتى
الان هم فاشلين وغير قادرين على تحقيق هذه
الاهداف اذا ماذا عليهم ان يطلقوا الان
هدفا جديدا وهو محور فيلادلفيا الان فشلهم
في خانيونس وقبلها في غزه وقبلها في
الشمال سيدفعهم الى يعني الانعطاف نحو او
الاختباء نحو هدف جديد وهو محور فيلادلفيا
وفي هذا المحور انا بتقديري سيكون في
استفزاز لمصر سيكون في مزيد من القتال في
هذا المحور اي وبالتاكيد لن يحققوا اي شيء
لانه المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي منتشره على
مساحه 365 م لا يضيرها من قاتل في الشمال
ومن قاتل في الوسط ومن قاتل في الجنوب
سيقاتل
في في في رفح وفي محور فيلادلفيا هم طبعا
يتذرعون بان قياده المقاومه لانهم لم
يجدوها في اي مكان وخاصه في خانيونس فماذا
سيقدمون لجمهورهم وللعالم لانهم فشروا
وانهم هزموا